[Music]
I think a millennia from now people are
going to look back and say wow the late
20th century was really a great time to
be alive on this
[Music]
planet why 2K what does it mean using
two digits rather than four made good
economic sense but when workers Advance
clocks to the year 2000 the world could
melt
down our systems are broken we've got a
problem with a couple of d
this has to be solved it's almost like a
black hole the closer you get to it the
more it speeds up personal computers are
the least of it it's the economies of
the countries that are interconnected
this is clearly one of the most complex
challenges in history I pray that people
don't
panic I feel like our days could be
numbered it's a paranoid and
pathological time lots of weird stuff
happens there are people who are
deliberately predicting the very worst
militia groups worry that the US
government could grab more power where's
the lives that go out in Asia I'm
concerned about
terrorism chaos and confusion
everything's going to collapse there is
nothing I want more right now than for
the entire world
EXP
for